in a presidential election where both
candidates are well over 70
each has questioned the other's mental
agility our own errol barnett asked the
presumptive democratic nominee joe biden
about that errol good morning again
so the former vice president seemed to
bristle at that question
that's right good morning vlad you know
we had an opportunity to speak to the
vice president as part of the convention
for national
association of black and hispanic
journalists which is kicking off today
and we cover a wide range
of topics but as you know president
trump has made his
mental ability and agility a campaign
topic and vice president biden had
previously said in june
he's always cognitively tested on the
campaign trail
but i had a more specific question
here's the exchange
please clarify specifically have you
taken
a cognitive no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program you take
a test where you're taking cocaine or
not what do you think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
but i mean i'm so forward-looking to
have
an opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
now we asked the biden campaign this
morning if they wanted to add
any additional context to those remarks
specifically comparing
a mental test to being tested for
cocaine the campaign
has not yet responded the vice president
will hold a number of virtual events
this afternoon including one with
atlanta mayor keisha lance bottoms
she is one of his potential vp
picks and we expect an announcement on
that front in the coming days
vlad yeah errol i think also one of the
important points that he made in your
interview with him is he said that he's
looking forward to debating
the president of the united states
something that some of his supporters
have said
probably would not happen that he wasn't
interested in doing that errol barnett
good to see you again my friend thank
you very much for that